I'm David Miliband the sector of State
for Foreign Affairs of the UK I want to
answer a question about how important
education to international development
when actually two built-in security and
stability around the world surprisingly
perhaps for a from ministry we think
that educational is actually the heart
of many of the security and development
challenges the oil faces education
especially of women I've come today from
the London conference on Afghanistan
yesterday a strong feature of that was
the importance of education as a central
offer to the Afghan people and security
to deliver education especially for
girls is an important part of the
political equation that needs to be
developed in its neighbour Afghanistan
country now about hundred and seventy
million its neighbor Pakistan a country
of 170 million people I'm delighted that
the UK is sponsoring a education task
force with the Pakistani authorities
because with 22,000 madrassas around the
country competing and Pakistan with the
state education system it's absolutely
essential that education is that the
homes or any vision for the future of
Pakistan so by one of my first jobs in
the element was as Minister for schools
it's one of the most inspiring and
empowering part of the political agenda
the Millennium Development Goals insists
that universal primary education is
should be a right for all children
around the world it's a right that's
sadly lacking and I think that the more
we put education of a part of our future
say for me